francisco lindor roberto perez sandy
alamar will all be able to wear the
number 21 in honor of roberto clemente
tonight so will carlos carrasco because
he is a former roberto clemente award
winner carlos carrasco he will be going
up against kansas city beat him earlier
this year his very first start back on
july
26th there goes the bat
nice check that's the strikeout bubba
starling not in the lineup but still
showing his center field skills high
over there dugout hit the netting and
they play the ricochet beautifully
grabbed it right at the pine tower
swung out and missed that one was just
about a ball with off the plate
dozier strikes out back-to-back case
danny duffy and like carlos carrasco
he's familiar with his opponent tonight
and for danny this is appearance
number 22 and start number 18 in his
career against the indians
don't they say good morning good
afternoon exactly i mean
i don't know if he's checked into the
game yet
2-2 swung out and missed carrasco blew
it by him
two down
down goes oliveras and a good inning for
carlos carrasco he spanned
four in the first two frames
and now down he goes and that's duffy's
second
we head to the fourth inning of play
nothing nothing score at alberto montecy
will lead things off
well what a job by hernandez he just
stole a hit away
from monday you can see how quickly he
got up to his feet to make a throw
knowing that monday was running
reyes draws a two out walk and the
indians have a base runner
he throws that one a deep left field
that's going to get down one hop the
wall
reyes on his way to third he'll have to
stop there gordon's throw going into
second
but not in time for luke blow who has a
double and the indians have a two out
scoring opportunity now
now the pitch curve ball swung on and
missed he
struck him out duffy with the strikeout
we head to the fifth nothing nothing
scores
here comes the one-two swing and a
missed strike three
got him with a look like a split change
and
reynolds lunging line drive base hit
right field
on his way to third goes oliveira's and
the throw is
over the cutoff man they throw back to
second and in safely is lopez oh i think
he got his foot
he may have a challenge here oh yeah he
got him yeah
there it is that didn't take long did it
so the inning is over lopez
out there's a
one hopper that gets through and delano
de shields has the indians
setting the table up here in the fifth
inning well
as there's a perfectly placed bunk to
third they'll go to first
hernandez executes the sacrifice and the
indians now have second and third
with only one out and now it's one and
two on santana
and duffy gets out of it that was a
strike
oh
one for two and whit goes the other way
that's into right center field yes you
can cam do it
and he will and so whit
has a multi-hit game first and third
nobody out this is an
opportunity here the 1-2 swung on line
sharply that's a base hit
gallagher will come around and score and
the royals take the one-nothing lead
that's five straight hits off of carlos
carrasco
the two that ended the fifth inning and
the three that have started this sixth
inning so maybe he is
laboring a little bit
struck him out that might have been
another change-up that's six k's on the
night for carrasco all six have been
swinging
off the end of the bat weekly hit cesar
hernandez will give way
and luklow makes the grab no further
damage but gaza said he leads it one to
nothing
there's a base hitting the right field
and reyes will stop at second so the
indians
have two on with two out and allano de
shields already two for two tonight
coming up
and han makes the play on a soft liner
there you go
so alex goes the other way and on an o2
pitch
he is on with a one out infield single
see him he tried to do that that was
nice
line to right field and that's another
multi-hit game for olivares said how
about that hop
alex gordon is going to come around to
score
and olivares is going to end up at third
base
what in the world did that ball hit a
sprinkler head
oh wow no but man i've never seen a
bounce like that
in an outfield in the big leagues
nikki lopez goes the other way and the
royals are going to take a three-nothing
lead
they have scored two runs in the ninth
inning both with two outs
and for nikki lopez that is his third
hit of the game
one out away from making it two in a row
against the indians and there's a line
drive to left
alex is there and the royals shut out
the cleveland indians tonight
three nothing with one run in the sixth
and they added two more
in the ninth